since the unrest of three years ago more
than ten thousand two hundred people
have been arrested on tuesday five of
those people appeared before wanshai
district court in a case that has raised
concern that the space for descent here
is narrowing quickly if found guilty
they face up to two years in jail
the five two men and three women were
arrested almost a year ago and have been
in custody ever since
their crime publishing allegorical style
cartoon books that show conflicts
between sheep and wolves
in one tale wolves try to occupy the
village and eat the sheep who in turn
use their horns to fight back
the authors were all members of a speech
therapist union
they were arrested under a long dormant
sedition law that was last used
frequently in the 1960s during another
troubled period of hong kong's history
when there were violent protests against
british colonial rule
that legislation has been reactivated
just as a more draconian national
security law is being applied
hong kong police say that their current
and recent law enforcement actions are
based on evidence and have nothing to do
with a person's political stance
background or profession
the hong kong government insists its
judicial system remains independent
the intensifying campaign against
descent was underscored by president xi
jinping's visit to hong kong last week
he warned against a repeat of the street
protests of three years ago insisting
the territory
had moved from chaos to order adrian
brown al jazeera hong kong